(upbeat percussion music)
- A bird in New York City
doesn't have it easy.
Whether it's flying into a building,
a car,
a bicycle,
dogs, pollution, lead poisoning.
This is not nature's natural course.
We have interfered with it.
My name is Rita McMahon,
and I'm the co-founder and
director of the Wild Bird Fund.
New York City's one and only
wildlife rehabilitation center.
We take in birds that anyone has found,
and we do our best to make it whole,
so that it can go back to the wild.
The atmosphere at the Wild
Bird Fund is something
of a three-ring circus.
There's the iso room, the waterfowl room,
reception area, and downstairs
is a whole 'nother thing.
There are couple of
hundred birds down there.
They may be flying around in the air
as people are scurrying around.
Cleaning the cages, giving
them meds, and feeding them.
We deal with 135 different species,
this past week we had a
Canada goose, seven kestrels,
a rowdy bunch of juvenile herring gulls.
This year, 2016, we will
treat well over 4,000 birds.
By being in New York City
where the animal is found,
we are able to save many more animals.
They would die before they
could get help in another state
or another county.
People can come to you via subway or bus
and they can get the animal to you faster.
It's exciting, you never
really know who's gonna walk
through that door, or what
they're holding in that box.
- I was at my store and I saw the pigeon.
I saw that he was like bleeding
on the floor like pretty bad.
I didn't even know that
they took in pigeons.
- [Rita] It's okay, it's okay.
(gentle piano music)
Any animal that is picked
up is in really bad shape.
50% will die or are euthanized.
If we can reduce the suffering,
that's a good thing too.
But 50% go free.
When the bird's better,
you try to return it to where it came.
If it's an adult bird, it
might have family, friends,
it knows where to live.
The migratory birds, they're
just passing through,
you're really just trying to put them
in a safe place so that they can
continue their journey.